So Adam Smith's,
uh,
and this is what I want to
rush quickly through, uh,
his life.
You don't really know all that much
about his life and it's not as colorful.
And George, uh, who saw and then you know,
his major contributions, uh, eh,
his theory of self interest and how self
interest is related to come and good is
labor theory of value. His idea of
distribution, of value between Labor,
capital and rent.
And finally,
what is the most often cited with
his theory of the invisible hand.
So here it is. Adam Smith about his life.
He was born in 17, 23, um, uh,
in Scotland called the just outside of,
at the Moro,
which is a beautiful city if you did not
visit it yet. I like all mental you do.
Uh,
he entered the University of Glasgow and
interestingly at that time in the mid
18th century for reasons which is
beyond me and next to Paris and London.
And Edinburgh was the center
of the Scottish enlightenment.
Um,
uh,
then he also went to Oxford
and a in bio or college.
Um, uh, and the, in 1751,
he was appointed, um,
at the University of Glasgow
as a Prophet Glasgow.
I would not recommend as a tourist
destination by the Va. Uh, uh,
um, um, uh,
he became a professor of logic and
then he became a professor of moral
philosophy, believe it or not, right.
The person who is known
about self interests and the
invisible hand is major for
a job was professor of
moral philosophy of ethics.
And in 1759,
he published a book,
the book called the theory of moral
sentiments, which is a book on ethics.
Uh, well, we've,
you'll see this is a big issue whether
this book was written out of Expediency,
uh, he wrote it just because he wanted
to justify that he's a professor of moral
philosophy and he didn't really believe
in it because he was an economist,
a rational choice economist or of us urea,
a moralist as one of the big
questions. I think what, um,
uh,
scholars on Adam Smith a debating,
he traveled in Europe and this may
have been a turning point in his life.
He meets Voltaire and kills me,
a major economist off his time and other
representatives of French enlightenment
and French enlightenment may have
actually influenced him and pushed him,
uh, uh, after the return
of Glasgow, uh, to,
and the guilt card,
what have I leave him back.
And that's what he mainly wrote
the valves of nations. Right.
And that's the most important book.
But I think in order to
understand, uh, Adam Smith's,
we have to come to terms with,
be the appearance,
tension between the theory of moral
sentiment and a vessel of nation.
Is this the same altar or these
are two different authors, right?
Is it the same theory or there are
two different theories offered to us.
And that's, I think very complicated.
He passed away in 1970. Well,
I wanted to find you some figures about
pictures about his life. The only thing,
what I could find this,
um,
a memorial on the site where the
house jewel in Kilgore devout,
he wrote a diverse of nation.
So it's not only a university VG,
sterning building downs,
even the British do turn or the beer,
the exam,
even if they should not have done so.
Right.
Would be so nice to visit the house.
That diverse of Nation of was written.
Like if you were to kill Cordey well you
can visit that site and to have a lot.
Okay.
So as I said,
Adam Smith seemed to
have two faces regularly.
Normally today if you take
economics classes right,
he is presented as the person who is
advocating the self-interested individual
and uh, uh, uh,
committed at theories of the self
regulating Marcus of the invisible hand as
little government as possible.
Poor soul,
just yourself interests and your self
interest will leave to the common good.
So he is the sort of inspiration for now
classical economics and rational choice
theory, right? And methodological
individualism to put in this way.
But he has this book,
the theory of moral sentiment in which
he's writing about sympathy as an
important motivation for human action.
And is this just a concession to his job
or is there something deep in him which
also showed the need for a helping
hand by the public authorities?
That's the big puzzle. You know, we
have to struggle there. Uh, there are,
there are other people who are more
qualified to give you the most authentic
interpretation of Smith. And
I try to do my best. Okay.
There are, um, and indeed, you know,
diverse of nation looks like about self
interested individuals and the invisible
hand ivy present you enough
citations that you see it.
I will also show you why it is possible.
Some,
some of, uh, Smith's interpreters.
I will suggest that this is the same
mill and the fact the vast of nation is
just an extension of the theory of
moral sentiments rather than I come the
addiction to it. I, this is
not the majority view right?
Today among economists in particular,
the majority view is that,
you know,
you should not really pay much attention
to the theory of moral sentiment.
The vast of nation gives you
the real source and inspiration.
And this is what the
guides, uh, um, uh, uh, uh,
no classical economics,
but you may find some economies to
disagree and you'll be fined a number of,
uh,
political philosophers who will disagree
and will say that this is not the real,
uh,
um,
Adam Smith's was presented to
you by now classic economist.
Um, and I don't want to take
a position in this, uh, uh,
I'm not a sufficiently, um, uh,
Smith scholar to be able to do so.
What have you presented the argument
both ways and you can make up your mind
right there.
You stand on this.
So the theory of moral sentiments
just very briefly, but this is,
he does ask the central question,
how can we make more or judgment?
How can we tell good from evil,
good for bad.
Now, it's a very important
issue and question. Uh,
there are many, uh, uh,
founding theorists of modern social
theory. We're dealing with this.
The most important one we've, you're
talking about him at great at, you know,
in 15 minutes is
Frederick Nicha of course,
the genealogies of morals. This is the
central question there does, right?
Um, uh, our conception of
good and evil come from.
But Adam Smith's already here asked
this question and he said, well,
what does solution that inside you,
that is an inner person,
you are to people,
right?
You Act and there is somebody inside you
is watching you and they're the inside
you will, the hotel you,
you did something wrong.
That was not the right
thing to do, right? Um,
I think you should be able to
relate to this. I can, you know,
there is very often and in
nurse shelf in my shelf,
which tells me that was a mistake I did.
That was a foolish things I did.
I should not have done.
So I know people who've are very small,
right?
Uh, uh, in, in, in, in, in,
in impartial internal SPEC teacher.
I know people who have very great
difficulties there in ever that I made a
mistake, right? There are some
people who all of us blame others.
If things go wrong right now and I,
they have a moral problem, I would
say. So watch yourself. You know,
you may have a moral problem if your
inner self never tells you that you were
wrong and you are all those
lucky to be others, right?
If the is being spent wrong, then
you have a problem. Ethical problem,
at least this is Adam Smith's argument,
right?
Simple and persuasive.
Then he says,
this is something which is kind
of inspired by hops, right?
The are led by passion,
but now he is not emphasizing fair.
He said also by Sin Buddy.
That's crucial and that's the crucial
motion for those who emphasize that.
In fact, Adam Smith's in the
vest of nation is the same.
Adam Smith's as in the theory of
moral sentiments because Adam Smith's,
those who argue for Vaughn Adam Smith's
rather than to Adam's misses, right?
Say that he has a theory of humans,
which is a sympathetic theory
of humans. What drives us, uh,
that we have sympathy for others.
Other people's sympathies that
in interacting with others,
the are seeking others,
people's sympathy, right?
We try to please people, right?
We want to impress people,
right?
The want to have a reputation.
We want to have good reputation.
The want to act honorably, right?
So we are seeking sympathy,
we have a sympathy,
they have that understanding of
other people's human conditions,
but we are also expecting others
to understand us and value us,
right? Um, and I think this is a
very important and intriguing idea.
This a Ivr show that to show you later
on may not be completely inconsistent by
the idea that seeking self interest
is leading to the common good,
right?
Because indeed if self interest
implies that I all show wronged,
right? Uh, others to
respect and evaluate me,
that self interests also implied that
I want to good do good to others,
right? This is in yourself interests
that you can say, at the end of the day,
I am a good person. Right? Then in fact,
pursuing these self interest,
right,
may not be all that different,
right from the common God, right?
Because it is inside you. And that's I
think, uh, the way how he is being read.
And he introduces the notion for the first
time of the concept invisible hand in
the theory of moral sentiments.
But here,
the invisible hand is not what you know.
You are told Adam Smith's theory of
invisible and this it's not the laissez
faire free market.
It's the hand of God.
God guides us,
right to have a proper balance between
passion and sympathy and that is somehow
God's will. But we follow. That's in fact,
you know Ivy, we'll talk
about this later, dawn.
A big a deal is made out of Adam
Smith's theory of the invisible hand,
the term diversity,
invisible hand,
the term calm sub three times in his work,
right?
And in each time he's using
it in a different meaning.
The way how we understand invisible
hand comes from a section lungs in one
sentence in the vast of nation and in
fact it is specifically about foreign
trade, right? And International Trade.
Not a mug and more about the role of
the government in domestic affairs,
but it is about free trade,
free international trade in.
This is the context in which he's
using the invisible hand as it is being
interpreted mostly today by
Adam Smith's theories, right?
So it's intriguing,
isn't it? Watch yourself,
then you are coining a term because a
term occasionally can stick and then it
will be all that repeated to you even
if you use it once right in your life.
Okay. They're the vast
of nations. Where are,
these are the kind of table of content
you guys about the division of labor and
the termination of prices,
a accumulation of capital.
He talked lots about the evaluation
of societies hunting, grazing,
agriculture and commercial
societies. Um, uh,
he never used the term capitalism.
A modern economy was commercial
industrial society for him.
And then he offers a criticism
of mercantilism and that's
where he offers right?
An argument for free international
trade and that's where he introduces the
notion of the invisible hand and
then something is on taxation.
What I've y'all not talking about?
So the self interests and the common good,
right.
One of the biggest Jews and we have
to discuss when we are faced with Adam
Smith's and the arguments are if
you are interacting with each other,
do not expect Benner valance.
Right?
Do not to expect that somebody else,
there'll be charitable to you. Um,
there is also say if you are seeking self
interest specifically in the citation
sites for instant choosing your
employment, if you choose it rationally,
this will be in the common good.
And that will try to explain why you
seeking self interest in finding them job,
which is best for you is also the
best for society. And then, uh,
he says,
well,
the individual are the better judges of
their own interest than any statement of
law giver as little state as possible.
That's very,
it is coming from and we will
see how he argues the case.
So do not expect Ben Valance. Uh, okay.
This is a very frequently
cited sentence, uh, uh,
from Adam Smith's. It's not
in the text. Uh, um, uh,
I assigned for this course, it said, well,
it is not the Beneville
ranch of the butcher,
the brewer or the breaker that
we expect our dinner from.
But the very self interest of
the, of the, um, of the butcher,
I go to the restaurant, right.
I do not expect died, the cook,
right. Uh, to give them
a bpm me a good meal, uh,
because, uh, you know, I need a good
meal and you know, I, you know, I, um,
uh, I expect the cook to like me, right?
I want him to cook a good meal
because then I will give a tip,
right? It is in the self insurance, right,
of the waiter to serve me well
and certainly good food, right?
Otherwise I'd be not to go back again and
be, and not give her a tip, right? I've,
you're punish, right? It is appearing
to the self interest, right,
of the person for whom I expect
something, right? And not,
it's been a valance. Now he said, well,
the address ourselves and not to the
humanity of the people right now to their
self love, but we want people to uh, uh,
take advantage of this. This is
an interesting issue, by the way,
even in everyday life, right? That are,
I'm sure in this room that are people
who think about this differently.
Just to give you a very
personalized example. Uh,
my wife occasionally tells me this person
is not a good friend of yours because
this person only costs you when
that person needs you or this had,
this does happen. And my answer
overseas, and I think in this way,
deep in my heart, I'm a
Smithsonian. I don't want rents.
I don't want anybody who do not see
an advantage in interacting with me.
I want people, right? Who Ha,
who actually act out of self interest,
seeking my relationship.
It will be a bad relationship
if my friends or the things
that it costs them to
talk to me and they do not benefit
from the relationship with me, right?
I don't mind. Well, my children, right?
Just to act out of love and sort
of be a pain in the neck for them,
right? I want my children,
right. Uh, to uh,
see that having me as a father,
it's beneficial for them. Right?
That's a good relationship,
right?
Good relationships are all of us
based on self interest, right?
You don't want to have a lover,
right?
Who does not enjoy being your lover.
Right?
Therefore you want right people
acting out of self interest.
And I think that's what is getting
get here. He said, even the Bagger
here,
actually the citations as the beggars
are the ones who are dependent only upon
Benner ones,
but then he qualifies it.
He said that's the even for the
beggar is not quite true. Right?
The beggar view make some tricks in which
in in fact it's actually a veal appeal
to yourself, interests that you
are a charitable person. The robot.
Now self interest in
employment. He said, well,
it's a very good example then you are,
he said,
then you are choosing an occupation. Of
course you want to have a big job, right?
You want to be well paid, right? Um,
those of you who are in economics major,
you know, you may want to have, you know,
some nice job, you know, some a
brokerage firm in Wall Street, you know,
and every 10 years, you
know, um, bachelor's degree,
you would like to earn $100,000 a year,
right?
But why would you earn $100,000?
Because the employer gets
a lot out of these skills.
What you get out of year,
right?
And therefore it will be in the interest
of the society that you had the highest
possible salary because you made the
greatest contribution to the common good.
Otherwise you have done, we've paid
that high. Okay? So therefore you,
they'll try to find that occupation
in which you get the highest possible
reward,
but you will get only the highest possible
rate we about because you make the
most contribution.
You can bitch your talent with your hard
work and it's your skills to the common
good. Right? This is Adam
Smith's argument. It's a
persuasive argument actually.
Right? Um, uh, well,
I can go home. It's not
all that important. Now,
this is very important to individuals
have the better charge of their own
interests than anybody else,
right? And, uh, uh, uh,
Bell, this is, I think, uh, again,
extremely important and I'm sure
this classroom is divided 50,
50% along these views,
right? He said, well,
uh,
the individuals in their local
situations are simply better,
uh, judges, uh, to what is that
interest then? Any statement or,
or, or log either, right?
People should the judge for
themselves what they want.
And it should not be a government,
which is imposes it on them
right now. This is, you know,
a big debate right now for instance,
about the house, good insurance,
the Husky reform.
Should we let it up to people to decide
whether they want to have an insurance
or not?
Uh,
should we expect people to be individually
responsible for themselves to take
charge of their life?
Or should it be the government or
should it be a statesman? The log you,
the congress who takes care of people
and he, he clearly takes a position. No,
I think,
you know,
people are the best judges
of the theories. Now,
the Labor theory of value, and let me
run through of it. This is important,
right? His point of departure,
uh, comes from, uh, uh,
John Locke as we have seen.
And it is leading directly to
Karl Marx, Karl Marx, radicalizes,
um,
his position.
But the point of departure is clearly
Adam Smith's and the argument about the
little bird theory of tell you the
Labor is the measure of all values.
And then he said,
the whole produce belongs to the Labor.
And so far Mark's
completely I crazy right?
And event we will be
discussing marks. Um, uh,
but then he departs from it
because he has a question.
Where does the profit and revenue come
from? Mike's as discretion as well.
And he says,
exportation right?
Those who earn profit
explored the workers.
But Adam Smith has a
different view. He says, well,
those who were land capital and those
who offer land also deserve part of the
value. Now let's see how this
contradiction can be resolved,
how he's dealing with this.
How can that all value is created
by labor and belongs to the Labor?
And nevertheless,
the capitalist podcasts,
profit and the landowner
packets rent for the land.
Then here, this is really a
very much John Locke, right?
The value of any commodity
is uh, uh, uh, uh,
bell belongs to the person, uh,
you know of, possesses it. Uh, um,
and, uh, if you know, if,
if it is not for use or consumption,
but exchange,
then the value of this commodity is equal
to the amount of labor which has to be
put into this.
Libor is therefore he said the real
measure of the exchangeable value of all
commodities, right? Commodities
can have a use value.
They can be very useful and they can
have very little labored in it like fresh
air. But go by now we know fresh air
needs some, quite a bit of laborers do.
Um, uh, but, uh, the
exchange, Javier Exchange it,
you'll be guided according to Smith,
by Labor.
A few people accept today the Labor
theory of value, smiths or marks,
no matter what I did,
it belongs to the whole labor.
This is a very interesting argument,
right? He said, and this is where, again,
now John Locke,
right?
The property of every man
is his own labor, right?
And therefore every value is created
by these labor and therefore it has to
belong to the person
who, uh, has, uh, these,
uh, w own the labor. But
he said, this is true,
or societies be for capital is being
accumulated and the four land is privately
owned,
right?
So this is really an argument
for ancient societies,
the south capital accumulation.
And we saw private ownership of the land,
uh,
in these conditions.
If there is no capital accumulation and
no private ownership of land is commonly
owned, then the whole producer
of labor belongs to the Labor.
And this is where he marks the beauty
part dramatically from Adam Smith's.
So where does the profit
and Ramcom now, uh, uh,
our capital is simply exploiting
the workers. He said no,
there is a distribution of value
between Labor, capital and Rant,
right? Um, and this is reasonable, uh,
because um, the capitalist, uh,
offers capital, uh, in order, in fact,
advances capitol to the Labor takes risks
with this advancement of the capital.
Supervise is the labor process
and therefore it should claim,
right? Some profit from capital.
Otherwise we'll be a fool,
right mark to advance its capital.
And the same goes for, uh,
um, land that shortly, uh,
land owners also have,
you'll have to give the land site
in which production takes place. Um,
and therefore they really
should be able to, um, uh,
collect some rant on this land. Well, uh,
finally the invisible hand that
are three conceptions of this, uh,
uh,
I briefly pointed this out in
the theory of moral sentiments.
He said,
this is really God,
which gives us a sense of sympathy.
And 38 is a balance between passion
and desire and hunger for more and self
restraint to respect others and
earn respect from others. Um,
and then of course in diverse of nation,
this appears to be the,
the Bri marketplace.
And then finally he had the manuscript,
his goatee off drawn on me,
and he said,
the invisible hand is the hand of
Jupiter, the hand of Jupiter. Um,
because people at as long
as the are ignorant, um,
uh, phenomena lightening for
instance, but they don't,
cannot explain attribute to
the wheel of Jupiter, right?
Superstition, the invisible
hand is superstition. Okay.
So what is fun,
right?
That three instances where the notion
of invisible hand is used in each case
with different meaning and in none of
the cases exactly the same meaning as we
normally understand it.
Okay.
I think I am now moving over to,
uh,
John Stewart male and the two,
utilitarianism.
Um, and uh, yeah,
he's a wonderful
man.
Um, and it makes a lot of, uh,
well I'm on the long,
long fire.
Okay.
So this is all about,
okay.
Utilitarianism and liberty and,
uh,
the long growth from Jeremy
Bantam to John Stuart Mill.
Uh,
um,
utilitarianism is a fundamentally
important proposition.
It informs a modern economic theory and
18 forms political and social theories
be charged in the kind of rational
choice mod or the theorizing.
And the point of
departure, um, is a Bantam,
um,
uh,
who in many ways is the founding father
of utilitarian is though he never used
the term.
Um,
and he influenced the life of
John Stuart mill in a major way.
A meal. Father was James Smeal, um, uh,
quite an intellectual.
He wrote the big three volumes,
history of um, uh, these, uh,
in India and a British
involvement in India.
He met Benton in 1808,
and he fall in love with the theory of
Italian and he asked him to supervise the
education of his son,
what he did and sort of where,
um,
John Stuart mill grew up
under the influence of a
very strong father and a very
strong teacher. Um, and uh, uh, uh,
he invented the term,
uh, John Stuart Mill,
the turn utilitarianism in
1822 at a very young age.
Um,
then he suffers a nervous breakdown
when you see what a utilitarian is.
Ms You will not wander. I mean, uh,
if you are a real yes, children,
sick, utilitarian, difficult to
survive this out and nervous breakdown.
Uh, alright, so what is
Bantam theory? Right? Um,
he published the book the principles of
morals and legislation in 1789 and there
are some very important
claims in this book. Uh,
Andy at first instance, they
sound very reasonable. Uh, but uh,
he may be pushing his luck
too far. He said, well, uh,
the are created to seek pleasure
and to avoid pain, right?
We, and therefore, if we can minimize
the pain and maximize the pleasure,
that's when the achieve
the greatest happiness.
And that's what we called
utility. Right? Um,
so action is right.
If it is leading to happiness,
we all want to be happy. Uh, okay.
Um, well, uh, and this can
be actually quantified.
The action is right morally right.
If the sum of blessures minus the sum
of paints mildly Levi by the number of
person affected by action is positive.
Sounds reasonable, right? Uh, if
more people are happy in society,
then unhappy, then the society
does as well as it can. Uh,
that's uh, you know,
the, the argument, uh,
well there are a couple of citations.
I don't want to fail on this too longer.
I will put in on the Bourbon.
It's not in the tech side
require from you to read. Um,
so he said, you know, the two big
masters, our pain and pleasure,
somewhat of the kind of
similar argument to hops.
And he said an action may be said to
be conformable with the principle of
utility. Man, the tendency is
to augment happiness, right?
Um, uh, and that is greater
than to diminish it.
And what is utility utility?
Is that principle Meijer approves or
disapproves of reaction to augment or
diminish the happiness of the party
whose interest is in question?
Right? This is a notion of utility,
which is not all that far away.
What economists start using eval at
this time. Then he comes something.
But I think nobody would accept now that
simply he said that it's easy therefore
to calculate it. Right? Uh,
and I already pointed this out,
you just count the number of people who
are happy and who has been a kind of a
number of people who are happy
with it and have pleasure.
And if more people have pleasure,
the sum total of pleasure
exceeds the sum total of paints.
Then you got the good society. That's
a utilitarianism, Allah Bentham.
Now, John Stuart Mill, um, here he is, uh,
uh,
he was born in London and he never
attended school. He was a lucky one.
Uh,
but not necessarily all that lucky because
his teacher was Benson and John Mill
who were tough people and yet had to
start learning to hack in and Greek man,
he was three years old.
Well,
if there are anybody who is
an Asian American in the room,
uh,
Chinese,
you may have to start actually how to
read and write in Chinese pretty early.
But he did the v the street,
Latin and Greek,
which to my mind is a
bit easier than to then,
or the characters in Chinese. Anyway, 22,
we established a utilitarian society
and invents the term utilitarianism.
And then he suffered him a
nervous breakdown. I mean,
too domineering people in his life.
And then he also becomes very, um,
sort of unhappy,
right?
With the expediency in
emphasis on Utilitarianism,
right? Instrumental Ism, the
coldness of the arguments, right? Uh,
he actually beginning to,
becomes interested in poetry.
And then he meets a Harriet Taylor,
uh,
at wonderful lady, um, and a friendship,
a very close friendship is formed. Uh, uh,
Harriet Taylor was a fantastic,
uh,
intellectual as far as
we can judge, uh, uh,
one of the very first radical feminists
and had an probably extra ordinary
impact, uh, on the verge
of Jon Stewart Male,
if you would have been at a zero feminist,
he probably should have
put on, is very, um, uh,
Harriet Taylor as a quarter.
She probably quartered this work.
I mean,
she was married and this
was an interesting triangle,
which did develop, I
mean, uh, in what way?
We don't quite know what they were
traveling together. The threefold,
uh, entity. Quite
interesting. I said, well,
uh, 51, Mr. Taylor
basses of, and then, uh,
John Stuart Mill, immediately Mary's
Harriet Taylor. But unfortunately,
she has a very short life and
dies after the short marriage.
So his, uh, undisturbed
happiness to put it this way,
did not last very long.
Um,
and he died in [inaudible] 73 in Avignon.
Now about the work,
uh, briefly, uh,
we'll be talking about three pieces of
work on liberty. Uh, utilitarianism,
uh, uh, uh,
ivy or not talk about his role as a
member of parliament without actually,
he was one of the first
advocate for a female suffrage,
um,
of which did not fly at that time.
And he even lost reelection probably
because he advocating voting rights for
women.
And then he wrote a 69
a subjection of the man,
which is in many ways is a feminist book.
Uh, quite a radical feminist
book. Um, a feminist book,
you know,
you can really read four for men
and especially the not in 1869.
Um, okay. So what are
his major contributions?
He redefines utilitarianism,
right? As I said,
he felt it too cold. He needed, you know,
more sentiments, right? Uh,
poor tree had you tailor,
you know,
if him of sense of the verb,
which is richer in 70 months.
So he has a says, well, there are,
that is higher mass,
right?
That is a lower level of happiness
and then a higher level of happiness,
uh, to have a good steak.
Uh, well it is pleasurable,
but to listen to,
uh,
the ninth symphony of Beethoven
manage greater happiness,
right? It's a higher
level of happiness, right?
When you hear the concluding core
out of the ninth simply right,
you are through the roof of Blusher,
right?
You have a higher level of happiness,
then he'd be eating a nice rare steak.
Huh?
That's the higher level of
happiness. And he said, and he,
nobody argues it more forcefully than him.
Individual Liberty is the
ultimate value and expediency.
And you know what he means by experience?
You right?
That you get there by using the least
means and you maximize a dirty term.
Expediency cannot justify intervention
against individual liberty.
Very interesting issue and very accurate.
Very up to date issue. Right? Uh, uh, uh,
just, uh, think about, uh,
uh, mine, the lava, right?
This is exactly the problem after nine 11,
right?
How much of we can act against individual
liberty in the name of expedience,
right? How much we are willing
to accept the limitations,
individual liberty and a bell of Evo.
See he said,
expediency is not to be
ignored, but, uh, um,
Ben, the chips come down. He said,
it is individual liberty.
He's a libertarian, right?
He is for the sanctity of the
liberty of the individual.
And he's the ultimate of
British individualism, right.
And the sacredness of British
individual, isn't it? And finally,
the third major contribution,
he said,
the most legal situation
resembles those of slaves.
The are only verse off that slave side.
And he argues that in a very
articulate today, and you know,
women should heavy for rights
in jobs in public life. Uh,
the same kind of education, total
confrontation. We drove up close. So,
um, uh, but he believes that in marriage,
the Gan create a
friendship bond with males.
Well, Harriet treatment did not quite
agree with this door. She married twice.
Uh,
she boasts times did it probably
reluctantly she did not believe in the
institution of the marriage
though she did Mary Rice.
Okay.
Uh,
well let me see whether I can
still do this. Um, his, uh,
staff on utilitarianism and
leave the rest for, uh, uh,
Jersey. I think I have some
three more minutes to go.
The teams in the work,
utilitarianism is the concept of
higher happiness and human beings have
faculties for more elevated, right. Um,
uh,
advertise that animals have.
Then he talks about justice and legality.
It's a very complex issue,
but he's thinks that the law is a more
restrictive notes and then justice and he
stands for the idea of justice, uh, uh,
and show some contradiction
between law and justice as such.
And then he talks about
justice and expediency,
why justice cannot be simply
explained by expediency. Uh,
well, uh, again, something,
it's speaks from very much through
the issues which is on our mind.
Just expediency makes it just that you
Kocher and l bladder or a business owner
or a suspected their quad a prisoner to
get information out because this way you
save lives. I, some people will say yes,
this makes it just others who say,
no,
it is unjust and therefore expedience.
You should not use expediency that you,
that you get better information out,
uh, from, from Doris. Sure. Well,
I think I probably leave it here and
then you continue with them. Uh, uh, uh,
uh,
Tuesday and I hope it got you up in speed.
Right. Um, um, uh,
usually Italian is my John
Stuart Mill and Adam Smith's.
And you see how actually, um, uh, uh,
John Stuart meal and utilitarianism
radicalizes one stream of thought of each.
He is in Adam Smith's,
but Adam Smith is not quite ready
to go as far as Benton then.
And even not as far as
just your meal, Matt. Okay.